champion of all time Mr Magnus Carlson
on the Multiverse where would you like
to go to the Sun
to the sun boom
I'm not feeling it oh man I took that
guy down with my Rook I'm so badass and
your dad is like Magnus remember where
you come from that was the worst
Norwegian accent ever
think about Chess Geniuses is hanging
out in their basement and obsessively
like chewing on their own skin and you
know maybe bodies hidden somewhere in
the house well you know I'm only 21
years old so give me some time to
develop the crazy you know
good what would the first sentence of
your autobiography be I'm not the genius
and what was the title of your
autobiography be martinus Carson chest
dreams I don't know